that required a hell of a lot of wisdom
I know more than the vast majority of
people are more experienced than
anybody's ever run for the office and I
think I've proven myself to be honorable
as well as also effective wow that's
Joe's pitch the voters think it's time
to ditch Biden making the case for
re-election touting is qualified
qualifications of being an old fart and
knowing a lot of stuff but the vast
majority want to see him retire eating
ice cream a new poll shows the
president's approval rating at just 36
percent that's a new all-time low
Democrats don't want the guy either 58
would rather vote for someone else and
Biden is hemorrhaging support from black
Hispanic women and moderate voters is
constant magabashing is also backfiring
he's losing to Republican Rivals Donald
Trump and to a lesser extent Ron
DeSantis
it's a brutal bunch of numbers right
George
this polish is brutal for President
Biden absolutely George and you talked
earlier about that record low approval
rating for President Biden it's actually
six points down just since February and
the skepticism over his leadership
extends deep inside his own party I was
told I could not send the poll around to
after 12 midnight I sent it out at 1202
because it kept me up that Coalition
right now is fragmented that should
concern them that's not a good number
for President Biden two-thirds of the
American people say he's not sharp
enough to be president
Joe's numbers are terrible and he knows
just who to blame
all they've heard is negative news for
three years everything is negative I'm
not being critical of the press but you
turn on the television the only way
you're going to get a hit is if there's
something negative you know you don't
anyway
that's number one but number two I think
we're in a situation where you have
much of what we were able to do only is
going to come into come into play now
you know Jesse the pro a lot of
everybody complains about the Press
but how can he do that when he has most
of the mainstream media behind him and
also he basically bashes half the
country every chance he can he should
not be complaining about who bashes who
he basically says half of the people are
just unsavable right this pulls like the
girl you say you hate but the minute she
looks at you and smiles you fall in love
I love this poll from the bottom of my
heart and this tells me two things I've
been highly effective and have been able
to persuade the American people
2 3
2 3 and unhealthy half-wit who's making
their lives miserable it also tells me
that the Biden protection racket is
failing they have tried everything to
hide this guy to cover for this guy and
it's not working and that gives me hope
sometimes as a republican you get a
little down you look at these numbers
you feel like you're under siege and
you're like oh God here we go again I
see a poll like this and I get excited
that thrill just went down my leg the
last time we all have to remember how
lucky Joe Biden got he had covet he had
big Tech he had the CIA FBI he had
everything going for him and it had to
work out perfectly
are they going to be able to pull that
off again I mean if he's at 36 percent
now with a summer of high gas prices a
teetering economy bank records that are
about to explode and a spring offensive
in Ukraine that could go sideways like
that and title 42 ending It could only
go lower I had a dream last night I
often don't tell people my dreams I
don't think it's masculine but this
stream was so good I felt like I had to
share I had a dream on Saturday night
that the Elders of the democratic party
sat Joe Biden down and then wheeled him
out in front of the American people and
said it's time to go
I'm not going to read into it anything
more than that I also dreamed like a
dunk but this was a powerful and
symbolic dream the fact that he said
he's an honorable man after he's denied
any responsibility for this illegitimate
granddaughter after this disgraceful
exit from Afghanistan you said it he
called half the country Neanderthal
neo-nazis and then he says he's
effective effective at what I mean he
broke the Border prices are up wages are
down I looked today it said the stock
market's only up seven percent since Joe
Biden has been in office that's not a
very good record but I just want to
thank ABC Washington Post for not
juicing their own poll it looks like
they forgot to juice it thank you Harold
uh by the way
yeah it's really good to see you too
um within that screen there was
something he said that was really
important it was that the dams might
love this poll because maybe it's the
the excuse they need to push him out and
then they like to pull because Trump's
doing so well that maybe they in their
heads the preferable matchup will be a
non-biden and a trump with is that fair
to say that they might actually like
this poll I also like the fact that he
could dunk in his dream as well as it
got got me going a bit two things I
don't disagree with them you have to be
alarmed if you're in the white house
with these numbers for two things one
the head-to-head matchup with Donald
Trump the president's now down now we'll
argue one they'll argue that the
Democrats will come back to him but the
Democrats should be there now and that
number is an alarming number two uh 58
of Democrats want to see someone else
run uh you and I differ a little bit on
this about RFK I think he's a serious
guy I'm not a serious candidate the
president and the same is true for
Marion Williamson which means to me that
a Democrat who's a sitting Governor
sitting Senator uh or a sitting
congressperson may say or sitting
elected official may say you know
standing standing or sitting as long as
they're in office may say you know what
maybe it's time for me to think about
this if you look at that 25 23 to 30
percent the two of them combined Kennedy
and Williamson are polling at
um that means that there's and I argued
the judge and I had a little
disagreement about this if it's four
weeks I only met four to ten weeks from
now just because we're getting closer to
them when you have to decide if you're
going to do something serious some in
the party are going to say look anytime
you face a difficult primary H.W bush
face one Carter face when they lost
Carter entrance interface one to Kennedy
HW phase one with Buchanan and then they
had good candidates run against them
this is a recipe for a loss so if I'm in
the white house you got to get him out
talking about the things he hadn't done
as well as people want you're seeing the
same polling it's the Border immediately
it's the debt ceiling get a deal in the
debt selling and claim victory show up
at the border like presidents used to
show up in Iraq and Afghanistan in the
middle of the night saying wow I didn't
know where he was going and she was
going and take the vice president with
you and commit to doing something over
the next few weeks even working with
Democrats and Republicans in the
Congress if you're serious about winning
and I think if you're serious about
doing what's right for the country
finally it is May 8th a day before it
important birthday and three days before
another month the day the day before
Dana's birthday you were still November
2024's election now in the midterms we
thought the Republicans are going to
sweep up we thought Republicans are
going to sweep in the house in the
Senate but I will say this this is not
to degrade or diminish at all this poll
this is something that we that the
Democrats in the white house should be
alarmed about because this is not a
one-off these polls have been trending
this way for a while so I hope I hope
the one thing that's different this is
that he's losing to Trump in a
head-to-head this is reason to be
serious about this Democrats as we head
into the summer
thoughtful but again I zoned out it was
a rough weekend but there was a really
positive thing in here I found about the
uh Hispanics and women in Blacks taking
a major hit it could that be a sign that
maybe identity politics has also kind of
worn its way out great Point thank you
that you know what he can Pander as much
as he wants to but he's not going to
bring people along with him what brings
the public along with a candidate is
when you have more jobs like black
students under the Trump Administration
than ever in history women having more
jobs Chinese minorities having more jobs
you know what I think Americans are like
they're they're they're they're
sensitive to the fact that they're
trying to sell themselves to them and
they're not buying it anymore look the
president has spent the last two weeks
out on the road and guess what happened
his numbers went down so you can tell
that what this Administration is going
to do is they're going to keep him in
the white house and they can't keep
doing that but this guy made a promise
in 2020. he said I'm going to be the
adult in the room I'm going to restore
America's to its moral standing I'm
going to make the historic role
Americans historic role is a safe haven
well what do we have what we have is 5
million illegals plus one million got
away so much for making America a safe
haven restoring our moral standing after
Afghanistan what we saw there is an
embarrassment and the truth is that he
comes out today he has a press
conference on air travel nobody cares
Joe and you know what he says at the
press conference he says and he says
Pete Buddha judge I want to compliment
him on his leadership and in the
interview with MSNBC he says Kamala is
doing a really really good job you're
full of crap everybody knows you're full
of crap they're not buying it anymore
there you go you know Dana do you think
they're going to just hide them again
now that like the Joe show doesn't work
so Hayden Biden is back maybe
um it reminds me of that movie that
Eddie Murphy was in when he was going to
run for Senate and he had the same name
as the white guy
distinguished gentleman and then he
never he never showed up he just like
drove around in a truck that said his
name yeah and he got elected and people
like oh we didn't know that that was the
guy so the you know sometimes you can
hide and your numbers will be better so
Harold said something that I had written
down he just didn't quite go there all
the way which is it's only a matter of
time when you have numbers like this
that they start floating trial balloons
of other names Governor Newsom remember
we were talking about him Governor
Whitmer uh Wes Moore Josh Shapiro all
sitting and standing Governors for
example so I think they're at the White
House in more of a panic than they are
letting on do you remember do you know
the meme you might not know the meme but
everyone at home does the dog sitting in
the room and there's fire all around and
the caption is this is fine yes that's
literally the Oval Office at the moment
and I feel like he also has had this
problem where he's focused on things
that people don't really care about like
a game of telephone so American people
called the White House and said okay we
are concerned about immigration crime
and inflation
and Joe Biden heard okay you want me to
double the size of the IRS and you want
me to give rich people
deals on electric vehicles and you want
me to figure out a way to debase
America's standing in the world got it
and that's what has happened and so I
think that they're starting to see
erosion from the people who said fine I
I will never vote for Trump I'll only
vote for a Democrat no matter who it is
I think that erosion is going to start
happening and that's what's showing up
in this poll you just gave me an idea
either for a segment or a book Dana
describes memes because we have a large
blind audience and you can't you can't
Braille I mean you've had the idea can't
Braille meme but like it's rude what
what no but you can I I found that
really helpful too when you explain to
me yes it was right yeah you can see I
can see barely I am legally blind
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now